hey what's up everybody Anna Mack here
for anime up or welcome to another
episode of rant cafe special episode
here we got a bunch of awesome guests
including nobel from lost paws what's up
man
Oh itself what's crackin everybody say
what's crackin yeah that's right that's
my catchphrase what's crack-a-lackin'
yeah glad to have you man first time on
rang cafe
also first time i wreck of a we got the
king of one piece pirate king if you
will teching 101 what's up bro I'm good
I'm just this was last minute but I'm
here so I've no idea what's going on but
let's do it
none of us yeah not what stuff any idea
was gone because we also have the old
the old crew old anime and NOx Taku in
the house speaking of which
NOx tacos computer [ __ ] broke guys
it's done he has a laptop it's a Mac
laptop that's his whole YouTube game is
going on that's right that's right low
budget operation here it broke the
Titanic everything everything went to
[ __ ] and now we are switching channels
where we were supposed to stream also
knocked his honest phone so are we gonna
even be able to hear him throughout the
stream no one knows it is quite a it is
quite an involved billion mark we got
planned for you guys yeah knock do you
want to try to introduce the tournament
arc because this was your idea
sure no problem the tournament arc is
the most hyped arc in any show so this
is the most hyped series of rant cafe
episodes or basically we have a bracket
here that's the some Twitter and it's
also the thumbnail and we vote to see
who wins and no one's ever happy with
the winner because everyone votes for
someone that lost welcome to anime
discussions that's right well I mean one
piece won last week so like I was very
yeah but no but you're the only one who
wanted that it was on your channel
everyone watches Naruto on your channel
she was butter narutards a straight up
slur in this world
no are there bubble retards though is
that's the question no I think I don't
think so I think that generation is kind
of dead but it's just got here
Bart is kind of fading away yeah I don't
watch it I really have no idea what's
going on right now I'm personally I'm a
calming itard everyone knows that so I'm
I'm proud of that guys so if you look at
the description I linked to a tweet
where the tournament chart made by all
day anime should be in there got it out
should work because I am very proud of
this bracket I think it pretty amazing
yeah crazy great job it looks pretty
sexy yeah I'm gonna put up on my big
screen but even if the matchup like oh
my god the thing is about the last
Chairman Ark was on the top shown in the
top shonan's according to a shounen jump
these are like the most badass
characters and they're all good so this
is gonna be brutal all it's gonna be
hard it's gonna be a bloodbath it's
gonna be it's gonna be pretty messed up
yeah yeah and and this isn't even some
of the craziest characters that we have
ever in anime like I said we don't have
calming out here we don't have a loose
like that's for another episode but
that's gonna be crazy um yeah we're
gonna milk it for you boys so I mean I
looked at this bracket and I just see
edgy characters is this at badass of the
edgy characters which one is it well
it's kind of well it's Knox Taku guys he
is edgy so to him yes I think he's edgy
but he thinks his badass that's how
that's how he rolls but I love them but
I'll have to crown the winner as like
just the edge Lord
yeah the edge look horde yes goes to the
edge Lord so how are we no links are in
the description as well just to get that
out of the way and now guys
Knox please tell us how you want to
begin this
the first one the first one is Xaro from
one piece against kampachi from Bleach
hold it Briggs are killing us already
okay alright I don't have any votes I'm
just gonna go with Zorro
really throughout the bye
as someone that has talked about bleach
for five years and now mostly talks
about one piece this was probably my
favorite one I gotta go I think I'm
gonna go kampachi though I gotta go with
him alright so one one yeah the reason I
put them together I'm like they're both
ridiculously strong use swords and have
zero sense of direction so I thought
that went together well yeah yeah but
I'm gonna have to vote for a chem Pocky
which is very surprising cuz I'm the one
Wow I think you've been watching but I
think I'm gonna have to go czar oh I
think he's for sure the more biggest
badass hand in all up to name in law so
it's one two and Noble is the deciding
factor alright so they're both swordsmen
right we all know this they're all
badass they take tons of hits and
they're still bleeding everywhere and
they're still able to do badass things
right like everyone else but there's one
thing can patch it has over Zorro oh no
that's his shoulder lolly so I'm gonna
have one piece sooro ends up getting a
shoulder lolly oh yeah little samurai
girl that's how I cannot believe this I
cannot believe it I thought he was gonna
win I'm the one piece guy and I gotta
give it to kampachi
I mean you know I she was the best
character my honest opinion I disagree
urahara was the best character in Bleach
well yeah if we're gonna argue that I
guess you were hardest definitely get
some more brownie points than kampachi
for me kill ya lair I think me and
tacking are both like par the biggest
Lumpy's fans in this like in this chat
and we both voted for head Bochy bison
yeah I talked about bleach for a long
time on my chin
so this is something that's where I'm
like ah yeah if a man could weld bells
on his hair and have the stupidest
scared whatever and still be [ __ ]
badass like I'm sorry I have to give it
to kampachi on that with this shoulder
lolly yeah the hair is badass like you
got to be a real man to pull that [ __ ]
off so I do understand the logic there I
just just to clarify are we going by who
would win in a straight-up fight or we
just going by who looks more badass who
is more badass
no you're fair I think okay though it's
very subjective on how well how we view
like I'm not gonna go with strength it's
it strengthens the [ __ ] right yeah
yeah get this earlier and I'm like oh
okay well if we're going on that route
then yes yes strength so much from
shokugeki no souma against Vegeta so
yeah I have to go Kenpachi on that one
though so I'm really sorry oh man Vegeta
slaps Vegeta just to see some debunked
videos all right let's not do this we
don't want to start that again no bro
esken or slaps with G to come at me bro
okay moving on the next one Levi what oh
wait this is this is a long-running
issue anyway Levi versus Itachi from
Naruto all right I think that I like
attack on Titan and me by much more so
to me it's Levi no contest bro okay so
for me though it's counter Itachi
no contest he was a sick character he
got twist was his plot twist was one of
the greatest plot twists my little mind
has seen cuz you don't read the attack
on Titan manga yeah but he's not okay
well you didn't watch Naruto so you know
I didn't chill dude I didn't well you
didn't get up to Itachi
okay fine 1 1 go a lot of a lot of
passion
has drained out of me from the Naruto
universe when Itachi was first
introduced I felt a lot of passion for
him but I like Levi when he first like
showed up and just kicked Aaron in the
face repeatedly took down I don't want
to spoil things for people that haven't
read it but pretty much every fight
Levi's in when he hacks up Titans like
Christmas goose I gotta go I gotta go
with Levi let's just point out that Levi
kick Aaron in the face for his own good
yes that's the yeah good hello I don't
want to spoil Itachi but I will and he
wrecked everyone for their own good
mmm-hmm noble I was in my turn now okay
well I mean Levi he's named after pants
you know I can't ever like this shoulder
Holly made after peds I don't know about
this but I mean he's cool he does
awesome things but honestly um you know
the cleaning thing it detracts from me a
little bit well Itachi here he's
basically he killed his entire clan just
to save his brother like honestly and
the village and the village yes of
course
and like and he had to kill his own
parents just to do it like that takes
some [ __ ] bad-ass levels you know and
it hurts him and he did it just for
everything and he had to go rogue and
was still helping Konoha by being inside
i can't say the name ever correctly I
thought katsu whatever so I'm going with
the hot chick that's key to watch you
know don't [ __ ] me brakes don't break
you better vote Itachi oh man haha I
have all the power now who as we know
thanks for years man I did a little
weight but I want to keep my vote okay
so taking listen here so let me explain
something to you he lived his entire
life I for others he was used the most
selfless character of all time you
saying that kind of made me remember
that little flashback when the hokages
were brought back all that stuff that
they showed and now I'm starting to know
I got I got a say and even though he was
the most helpful good guy
okay guys don't matter I [ __ ] paid
all the characters from attack on Titan
I think they're bland and boring yes oh
yeah [ __ ] this I'm not even okay don't
get me wrong but not Itachi
no I'm not matter you don't want mad at
Briggs for say only one who isn't bland
and what longer the Aryan and I [ __ ]
care Aaron is kind of boring a little
bit as amazing
in the most recent are Keys kind of
warming up to me a little bit but for a
while there for a long time I didn't I
didn't really consider Aaron that much
of a manger well you guys don't relate
to my actually I was born during like a
civil war so I relate like a hundred
percent well there you go that's just
your perspective on that it makes sense
that my inductively accurate perspective
correct you're right taking my friend
okay let's remember who lost okay I
believe it was Levi fine Hitachi or hit
touchy or whatever wins but that's good
she I know no talk who donated $5 to say
holy crap its noble I don't care what
his argument is but he wins well yeah I
did win this one he did you're all happy
keep your old house you want last one -
yeah wait Noble has lost paws I just got
that oh nice to meet you man you like me
now yeah you knew all along he was just
tricking you
yeah well next is Todoroki versus soma
from shokugeki no souma I can I just go
really quick I've never seen shokugeki
no souma all I know about some as he
really raw oxen apron but that's not
good enough for me so I'm be one for
Totoro ki a same here I don't like soma
I love Totoro he's my favorite character
of the students in boku no hero Sol told
her students today Mitch with daddy
issues [ __ ] it Briggs not everyone had a
super supportive dad like you bro
alright so before we move on I just want
to say that um I loved Todoroki in the
tournament arc but I think after that
his character dropped
whereas soma retains his badassery
throughout and I vote soma a noble
character so you get more development
yeah
why did is so heal better I don't care I
like him through the tournament and then
I didn't like him after so I agree with
max Oh two-on-two and it's back again to
lost pause I'll up just for the record I
love food Wars and I love boku no hero
academia alright
I don't know what some was doing on this
list honestly um but I guess we'll roll
with it soma he's got some daddy issues
but not as bad as Todoroki alright
like he honestly wants to beat his dad
and his dad is basically his driving
point like to beat him it's like the
gold the anime to beat his dad right and
I mean he gets there he takes on entire
it's like hostile cooking Academy just
by his own wits and skill and he somehow
pulls it off every single time select
props to him you know but it's still a
cooking Academy but yeah I don't like
where this is going oh no he's got this
bad backstory
you know he's mama's scarred him for
life his father's a [ __ ] prick
[ __ ] you know and somehow he becomes
gay with Deku I mean I don't but from
that perspective every character is gay
with Deku I'm going to curate that
dojinshi with Totoro
Langton
why does he have a back and white man
it's like kind of like that guy who's
gonna become like the next Almighty in
the series like besides of course Deku
there but I feel like Totoro Keys got
some more important things to play so
I'm gonna go to a rocky yes going man I
was a different story but I'm happy
finally
right did I lose against Vegeta next
tenuous expert the misdirect
I don't know about that Briggs good
rocky sucks
although the next one is Ursa from fairy
tale versus Vegeta from Dragon Ball this
is the only bracket I put 0 thought into
I wasn't sure yeah because I think it's
pretty much unanimous what Ursa has
boobs Vegeta well this one's unanimous
you who would you bang I would go with
Ursa um if it's me this is fair fair if
it's character like I don't know I don't
I like Herzl too but Vegeta I feel like
I grew up with him and I really like the
character he develops from like a
villain to a family man to like but he's
still like super proud and also he's a
Saiyan nationalist so I like that - um
I'm a big nationalist kind of
politically guy so I have to go with
Vegeta yeah me too same here yes in here
alright we all know Vegeta is badass in
everything and has four votes so far and
we know that Vegeta purposely put in the
Majin symbol on his head just so he had
a [ __ ] excuse just to [ __ ] just go
through a phase but do we really talk
about that arc like we talked about that
he redeemed himself from that though
like yeah he did something that was
stupid and yeah evil but here
from that and you know like I mean he
becomes a family man and basically the
cheetah has become the biggest male
tsundere of all time I think cat-back
ago is more of its underrated he's
definitely a tsundere
boy because he loves them and idolizes
in some way yeah so like love every such
she just likes cake uncle all right
Vegeta wins or something one-liners a
note alone I get the Super Saiyan
bargain sale so so it's a unanimous for
first time so far for Vegeta nice also I
definitely can imagine that he is a
classic zoom dinner but I don't think
that's a bad thing a man he's a male
Sundari and he's better than Bakugan I
don't care anyone says let's go I think
we need more of those males Junior's I
think we have a lot of those I think
cinder is my favorite dari type no one I
feel like should be on this list but
he's not but yes he's another classic
example the male suitor it my problem is
that in real life I tend to be a
chocolate only consume that chicks I
think it's an actual problem at least
it's not yonder it yeah but if a girl's
like screw you buddy I'm like oh my go
why doesn't she walk me nah
anyways enough of my own problems yeah
we'll get back to that later we've all
been there man we've all been there yeah
totally sort of next is he a from YuYu
Hakusho against kahlúa from hunter
hunter huh so hard yeah this was a WoW
yeah I was thinking about it and like
wow this is hard but I'm gonna start
things off voting for he a because he is
extremely badass and I don't know he's
just way more badass he's an ultra kill
oh yeah
I mean and they're both Takashi care
which is I'm sure why you put them on
there like that yeah I this was hard for
me because he a I grew up with he a YuYu
Hakusho was one of my first ever anime I
ever watched period and I'm just getting
into 100 I just finished up the Chimera
ant arc rather recently so this was
really hard but then the stat the kid in
me has to win out I gotta go with ta for
all those times as a kid that I'm
freaking out with the freaking you know
yeah
darkness flame stuff they're literally
Mecca now there's another male tsundere
for you yeah well that's true yeah I'm
gonna vocally wanna make an interesting
Kiley oh come on don't do that I have no
idea I can totally see an excuse for
kilowatt I thought they're so close in
badassery I like Kahlua a little bit
more but like I can't decide some single
Kahlua to make interesting definitely
didn't pick a badass facial expression
for Kilwa dude he's kawaii is [ __ ]
still badass yeah that's pretty much
he's a kitty face yeah I think because
hunter hunter is fresher in my mind and
Kilauea is just such a badass in that
makes gon look like a [ __ ] and going
it's pretty badass himself I'll go with
Killa
oh yeah you too great me again the issue
here is Nobles favorite animes hunter
hunting well I'm not gonna lie though
you knew haka shows the classic man and
I was totally digging that [ __ ] when it
was on to knob by the way did you hear
they're getting to coming out soon
they're gonna redo yes what the [ __ ]
they're making yeah yeah but for the
25th anniversary they're gonna re
release the whole series on blu-ray but
they're also gonna get the original cast
together to do two OVA 's I don't know
how long they're gonna be but they're
gonna do them oh yes I just can hear the
badass intro again I'm on for it like
you know yeah he was just oh no energy
alright
he's the embodiment of like the
old-school edge Lord this man he wore
all black we had like the Vegeta hair a
little bit you know he was all secretive
mischievous and did all that other
gnarly stuff
but Holly joined the demons and stuff to
be good also
he was demon me to his things and you
know to me I I like to cool bara a bit
more you know I'm just well cool Maya
isn't exactly badass mark you bet stable
here well he was tortured by his family
he grew up in like a top assassin family
place here like his name has kale in it
his name does have kill in the [ __ ]
thing and he becomes friend with like
and he gets like repentance from gone so
you kind of gets like this development
as a character he's also got the sister
that he wants to take care of despise
whole sister complex yeah complex broke
he wants to protect people like why you
think everything's a complex you weirdo
I was saying that to his advantage you
know okay I do the fun word to say
complex
I do think Kilowog has the edge of
badass well I thought you said that he a
had the edge contest so we're going
alright Briggs this is all your fault
for being indecisive and voting against
us kahlúa one sweet kilowatt all the way
Briggs say it it's also a coffee
flavored drink Kahlua so there you go
yeah well now which are you okay
kilowatt so its kilowatt and it's cuz
killers in the name but also his
abilities lightning so I always likened
it to kill a watt well I don't know if
that's supposed to be intentional or
what that's pretty cool
so honestly when I'm in a Kahlua video
the amount a comment they got people
correct and you know I still don't hear
the difference between what I say and
what you say I mean it's fine I mean say
whatever you want to say I mean yeah I'm
not the one that's gonna get bent a
pronunciation did oh yeah I [ __ ] get
everyone like I am
you guys make youtube videos you all
know how coffee how many you pronounce
this wrong it's like no you pronounce
the wrong [ __ ] I don't know where you
guys rap with me with me it gets to a
point where it just circles around and I
just don't care anymore
it's just I've lost also there's no
there's nothing left in me to get a [ __ ]
about pronunciation anymore in my life
so yeah but but it's still heat up G
sure that's Kakashi is Kakashi I'm like
sure that's the name of like another
manga I think quite or whatever sure but
yeah okay so Kim low winds good stuff
also tea matcha tea mochi donated five
bucks to say what about spike from
Cowboy Bebop that is not a shounen we
are going to do in the future a greatest
characters of all time kind of not
limited by Shonen and definitely spike
is one of my favorite pictures ever so
stay tuned
yeah well next one is Joe taro from part
three of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure which
unfortunately none of you have watched
an engine or actually watch JoJo's back
from freakin Barnes & Noble today oh man
I am so honored Wow Joe sir is actually
gonna get two votes maybe no no no [ __ ]
that
ESCA door all the way I love I was gonna
chime in with Escobar before you guys
even started yeah he's vote for me the
thing is as far as bad as I also vote
for his candor yeah boy even though I
love Joe Joe's no night forum is his
best forum ask adorn his night form
versus Lord Twigg oh I wanna see that I
don't want to see that I don't want to
see s can or get destroyed so badly even
in his day form Lord Twigg Oh would
demolish him he's secretly the demon
king after all he's really dead he's
actually the demon king did you not
watch my April Fool's video
oh did you not watch any of my videos
noble I'm waiting for that reaction
you're gonna enjoy Lord Twigg oh stop
okay stop guilt trip ignoble into doing
the Rocky
he's been doing that I don't do because
I haven't really seen JoJo's so if
you've never watched it before I wish
I'm gonna tell you I with the thing that
I wish people would have told me the
beginning of JoJo's it's about zombie
vampires cuz if somebody would have told
me that I've been like oh yeah sure
right away let's check it out no zombie
vampires was the worst our issues I like
zombie vampire or that got me into it so
yeah I agree that the next yeah those
are nazi vampire zombies Alucard needs
to be a so so I think this is also five
votes for Eskin or yeah I mean just an
original fight against Galan but I
cannot wait for esta rosa whenever that
that's been animated like that is my sin
and that is why I have advances alright
well next is ginto key versus Onizuka
Onizuka OD suka I really like I
personally like I like Onizuka a lot and
I and as you know I haven't watched
Gintama
so no no hate on Knox's favorite
boyfriend but I'm gonna go with Onizuka
I have never actually watched Onizuka
and I've seen very few episodes of
Gintama but I've seen a lot of just like
like videos and clips of game Toki so I
gotta go with King Toki yeah I'm with
you man Gynt okey all the way best
character of all time the boyfriend
though though every team Tama in when I
was like a kid in the old show ninja
shot magazines you actually got in
America like the actual magazines I
think I remember reading stomach yeah I
think it's 2-2 based off of my uh my
chanting at the beginning but personally
I've watched 80 or 90 episodes of
Gintama I think one is because more
badass overall and I'm biased because I
great to 21
my favorite animates of all time it is
amazing
great mister my big butt what am I
supposed to do here like I barely
watched any Gynt okey because it's just
like if I don't know I and great teacher
I haven't even seen that one so I didn't
know who to vote for for my vote doesn't
it based off of their facial expressions
their facially come on man you made the
bracket you can't do that to them look
bad ask like they're both kind of like
trolls a little bit you know I I don't
know I know
Gintama like that all anime is more
recognized than great teachers but so is
so much better I feel like I think no
it's not you noble I think you would
relate to Onizuka if you saw it I think
you would relate to him sure let's go
Onizuka why not yes life convinced
everyone's losing no one is well the
next one I don't know how it works
that somehow Briggs always wins what's
going on here because I made the broth
at least the next year this is true but
the next one you're gonna lose cuz its
sake from Kenichi versus Sinbad from
Maggie and Sinbad is extremely badass
and he therefore gets my vote ok before
tech gains vote I'm assuming you guys
haven't seen Kenichi other than me and
uh I've never seen what's the other
thing called Maggie yeah I've only seen
very few episodes of Maggie
so the fact I saw cookie here if I had
to like make this bracket myself I would
have him win it all like that this
Monday well that's just because you're a
kid Nietzsche fanboy I have Abbott's in
bad it's extremely powerful and aside
from that he's an amazing character can
his adventures of Sinbad we developed
him from this you know more of a naive
type straightforward basic character
that was just really powerful and Noble
and whatever well not you noble but
noble and in the actual Maggie series we
see him we see his light side as a
badass and we also see his dark side
where he's kind of a nipple ating things
behind the scenes to go his way also as
a badass
Kenny therefore wins so when I did my
fat ass when I defined bad ass i defined
she Osaka G like let's just like
nonchalant super strong he drinks his
beer he [ __ ] karate chops the top of
it open all right
drives a [ __ ] motorcycle he got shot
in the manga and he went to a tournament
anyway kicked everyone's ass he's so
strong he's no longer welcome back
that's how badass he is okay okay well
the whole the whole opening his beer
unnecessarily with a sword just screened
off Lord karate chop
karate chop whatever that screams ed
Lord just open the [ __ ] beer bro if
you could open a beer with a karate chop
would you do it though that's I mean
yeah yeah like am i impressing girls
yeah okay yeah I'm a fan of Simba and
myself I like like I like things like
actually that he actually is like
leading a country and taking
responsibility and like having to be a
good like a hero but also Machiavellian
so I just like I like Simba am I vote
for Sinbad is it over oh yeah okay so so
cocky i I've read the entire manga I've
seen everything I think he's really cool
and I thought he was a total pro he's
he's super he's got like I don't know
how many black belts and every single
karate thing ever
um he's he's the badass but his
character is just karate that's his
character like Sinbad and beer I mean
has many different layers to him he runs
an entire [ __ ] country he's got all
these he's even like embraces his women
as [ __ ] and everything he's a player
he's manipulative he's he's got so many
different layers to him that he's he's
actually cool so I gotta go with Sinbad
I knew this - rest in peace yo Socky he
breaks me for Levi so now you know how I
feel haha retribution well I guess well
we're beginning round two yay may I can
I go
another beer if you karate chop it yeah
if you karate chop it open because
that's apparently what makes you badass
that's how I define badness I don't know
but you guys I mean anyway while he's
gone let's dirt the next one so he
doesn't have to say anything bad about
Itachi alright or hit touchy-touchy it's
itchy
I guess mr. Shia the next one is
kampachi against Itachi that's a sick
one Hachi Itachi um I love kampachi but
I'm gonna still vote Itachi as the
greatest but here's the greatest
narrative arc ever yeah if we're going
on that route I mean with the different
layers to his character and stuff I I
gotta go with Itachi on that one whoa
you just voted Itachi over bleach and
one piece I know I know I know
well I it wasn't all three of them
together but yeah you know what I mean
yeah nice okay so I only trick Weber
beer guys if you're drinking beer again
so like we're gonna have a good time in
a Anatomy North because last year you
didn't wanna drink beer what I only
drink saw bro bro and he also only
karate chops it open I had that when I
went for an iced tea iced tea what are
you damn straight
okay anyway so yeah it's kampachi versus
hit a chi Ivo compile how I define bout
us you know so I'm voting kampachi I
feel like you just like a nicer guy
Itachi were like had like he's more deep
but doesn't make him more badass to me
yeah it does living his life zero
personal gain like for me like yeah well
kampachi I don't know that's a good
point
other thing kampachi all he cares about
is fighting and fighting strong foes I
think that's hella badass
he's like so proud that he wouldn't even
use like his second hour on how to watch
bleach in a long time
it wouldn't use a second hand he wore
the eyepatch I don't know that's
and that's more edgy than badass and
he's like such a straightforward
two-dimensional character don't get me
wrong I love him he didn't pop he'll
release because I keyed him on it like
he wanted his pure his strength
yeah later on I mean later on you find
out about that but I'm not gonna
yeah but later all right relevant all
right so it's 2-1 anyone else any input
the thing is both of these anime are
ones that I started but never ended up
really finishing and I I couldn't really
care less on this one well first off you
implied bleach had an actual ending
that's sort of like on the teeter-totter
right there yeah I know well I think
noble vote sees hacci so no I don't I
thought she's cool and all but like I
still thought he was me I don't like
sauce I think it's the Sasuke bit that's
rubbing off on a tattoo that makes them
more lame to me in my eyes like I I
can't I can't accept that whiny little
[ __ ] [ __ ] Sasuke is cool he's got black
hair and uses lightning you know it's so
great when when it's a group of
youtubers that aren't Naruto youtubers
everyone hates Sasuke but the Naaru got
Naruto guys they love them I don't get
it
you like Sasuke what the [ __ ] I like I
don't like Sasuke I just like sassy I'll
say this about nerds no man it's one of
the most passionate fan bases ever
that's like split right down the middle
on a lot of this stuff I mean they'll go
at it yeah [ __ ] Sasuke oh yeah yeah I
guess I'll just I'll just go with
kampachi to come 5dg though I can't
believe he died you lost also yeah I
suck anyway the next one is Todoroki cuz
he lost he beat soma somehow against
Vegeta Ivo Vegeta
yeah me too maybe it's just because
Todoroki is relatively like you know my
your academia is obviously not around as
long as dragon balls so there's not as
much development there but I gotta go
with the jitta over Turkey I'm gonna
well love them boys for me but I'm gonna
go with Todoroki even though I love with
jitta just because you guys both said
Vegeta salt I want to give Todoroki a
chance so well the chance is continuing
because just the tournament's are
cologne gave more character developments
- Todoroki than Vegeta ever got
throughout the entire Dragon Ball
stopped trying I do disagree I got a
disagree with that one yeah and I vote
for Todoroki Oh
pressures on
okay well the G that we all know he's
lovely
he's got all this badass levels of just
like first I want to blow up the earth
and then you know whatever and now I
even kill my own buddy because [ __ ] amis
useless now that's pretty badass in
itself because he just takes like oh
then he takes a son to an amusement park
he's he's a children do yeah but you
know he still does you know badass
father you think that still loves Bulma
especially when she got attacked you in
like he's like I'll [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] that's pretty badass
alright protecting your own waifu
alright Todoroki he's got no waifu
alright debatable deku at this point no
Todoroki vert.x mo mo guys like don't
even like oh yeah you're right oh yeah
that was set up yeah that one's that
one's pretty set up okay so you just
have a waifu wait I mean he's got the
tragic backstory for Vegeta
I guess his old planet is got destroyed
by Frieza and he was forced to serve but
so that's pretty tragic too
it's tragic but they really didn't dwell
on that and how it affected him
psychologically
why I know cuz just like [ __ ] it you
know it was like my planet was destroyed
nappa let's kill the Kakarot it's like
what okay
oh yeah Juba cheetahs murdered many many
innocent people if not yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I think looks a little more bad
is the fact that you're able to actually
know when to slaughter and when not to
do it and control yourself so I'm gonna
go to it roki oh yeah alright that's
pretty crazy
and I just wanna say oh wow that you
know some some fathers are not super
supportive of you when you're like doing
YouTube and stuff and then I get a real
job so you know what I relate to to the
rookie
my dad and then he then he destroyed the
planet anyway my dad's a pretty
supportive guy but yeah he did tell me
if had eyes like novel said if you
picked out a rookie a month seven all
right I'll say something I have no idea
what he's talking about
so sorry man and no idea what do you say
I'm selling a book a Kenny I don't know
if he means a Kenny from a target I know
South Park but I'm not Kenny is kampachi
income patchi's nickname Oh both
accounts Jesus okay yeah it's alright
with the five dollars though anyway next
is kilowatt verses Lord s Kannur where'd
the Todoroki a few win yeah oh my god
you guys are discuss what makes it
exciting
alright let's see what happens all right
I wrote for lure Destin or old bright
quirk son for old ii done for all praise
the sun for all for those of us who are
Christian praise the Sun wooden old
oh this is they're always asking or cut
to Jesus like snapping his fingers like
yeah yeah I know but we don't know we
don't edit I met Jesus at Echo actually
he's pretty chill dude nice I met Jesus
in my heart every day oh that's nice I
just have the Triforce in my heart
because I never really view him as a
badass character but he has his moments
but
yes it's moment yeah like the whole
thing about s Connor is he's like he has
these like peak badassery moments right
they just they just throw him on they're
like full badass like he like you know
it's just it's just so so epic so you'd
say I can't I can't not vote for him
well that was a sweep yeah
ESCA doors killing it next this great
teacher onizuka versus lord sim bed King
Sinbad
Mahalo whatever the contest at this
point yeah totally this is the thing
this is the thing what do you value more
like statesmanship or being a pervy dude
well Sinbad's a pervy dude by his own
right so I hope Sinbad hands down his
relationship with with the princess was
like the greatest thing ever
yeah Sinbad's pervy but he gets the
chicks whereas onizuka's pervy but he
doesn't really succeed so I guess love
Onizuka but I'm gonna go with Sinbad
just from based on what you guys have
been talking about Sinbad I'm gonna go
Simba he thought you loved you man I
need to get back in a man then that is a
sin badass sake
yeah what sorry man I'm still butter
alright so your vote goes into trash
anyway alright so we got four votes or
simbad one vote for sake key again
trying to revive him sorry Onizuka round
pretty crazy huh come on achievers is
Todoroki how did this happen Zara Levi
Itachi sama and Vegeta are gone and we
have these guys the pot the bottom half
is weaker the bottom how did that happen
well this is what happened Briggs talked
a lot of [ __ ] against Levon Todoroki and
now he's getting that car - face they
blondest leave it this is horrible like
how does our owe any tax lose so what I
made the bracket I was thinking of the
original like matchup
make them like very close so all the
originals are super tough but now that
the ones that like went through like
some of the weaker ones snuck through
that but to be guys against each other
right Todoroki in so much I put those
excuses buddy
Todoroki is awesome I'm coming up
excuses for your stream as to why if I
don't results suck no they don't screw
you screw everyone ok 5o kampachi cuz
[ __ ] Todoroki
I vote okey cuz Fogg Briggs that seems
rather bias Briggs is one of the only
dudes who knows that Amelia is best girl
yeah not threat so I am best ok best
girl is definitely hands down Rosewall
and whoever says differently is
obviously a fascist
[Laughter]
Rosewall is the only best girl I don't
even see any competition here
I love how noble might not know you as
well as we do fascist and I'm like what
ok whoa dot serious yeah I mean adamak
love each other we rip on each other
every stream no so you're a married
couple that's nice yeah married a couple
of straight guys okay right on Briggs
best girl go home gay and straight at
the same time it's perfect and it's all
good it's ok so we have one one one
right one told they're all buying time
here cuz no one wants to vote either way
it's tough oh my god voted for Todoroki
i have the power of butthurt mhm a fans
on my side no like I love kampachi and I
like to do love my Todoroki as well you
know but like I I have to go with
Todoroki because the one reason I voted
for him over vegeta and that's because
kampachi is just he's two-dimensional he
just wants to do badass things for
badass reasons you know like Todoroki
yeah he wants
badass but also be good and that is
today after all
you know it's a tougher battle alright
trying to do the right thing no bullet
per second so i'm going i'm also
Todoroki yeah sorry man yeah Briggs
bro what we get to praise the [ __ ]
Sun on okay what that's a likely
possibility
alright so speaking of the Sun we have
Eskin or versus Sinbad and this is a
crazy tough one yes I do agree to Rocky
is Zuko literally is yes
yeah just at a disadvantage because I
really don't know how Sinbad's character
is so I got a stick with the Sun gambit
on this one like I don't know anything
else about the guys so there you go okay
sold knocks will be happy with me on
this one because as much as I like askin
or I think overall so far Sinbad is the
better character so Sinbad for me it's
okay and you know and I love s Kannur
but I'm also steamed Sinbad here
Alaska nor does holy girl better than
roswall is Sinbad all he does is pity
you guys he doesn't have his own Kingdom
he was sick taro his own Kingdom Sinbad
has his own Kingdom bro yeah bro
yeah but s can or has a mustache Sinbad
the king right in bad the king well
kings are as plentiful as green the sand
of corn to Aspen or okay and he does
have a badass mustache I will be nice
well you know you do know where he got
his mustache from right wait was Lord we
go mom of course of course was Lord we
go I mean he's good I know he's cool but
he doesn't show up until like 100
million chapters into the [ __ ] anime
336 I don't know I just guessed don't do
like that
such minor character in the things where
Sinbad is such a prominent one you have
to go Sinbad yeah oh yeah suck it Sun
God
sorry Briggs dude I know the words file
bracket he lost everything he won all
the first rounds head he lost the rest
yeah by the way I'm dying here I know no
talking finally clarify what he meant he
says Kenpachi lifted a mountain using
nothing but spiritual pressure I've seen
that hentai and charged at a God when he
was said to be unbeatable pure badass
okay now I get what you mean what if
doctors Todoroki do okay so the finals
we find ourselves in that was that's
what that was my intro to this stream
we're gonna come up with finals that no
one's happy with so uh you know how I
posted our last like rad cafe I kind of
head it in and put it on my channel I
will not put this on my channel this is
just yes you're right they don't on mine
it doesn't deserve to go on my channel
yeah you know what's funny we should get
Nobel to put it on his channel so like a
million people see it haha I won't even
watch all the power I'm smashing the
dislike no I'm not this was great
sorry Briggs all right so I vote Sindbad
because you're gonna compare him to Toto
smokey Wow although honestly I do like
Todoroki but you can't compare it to
Sinbad he's just so damn cool yeah so
this is oh then this is the thing my
hero academia is starting out still
right so a lot of characters but they're
still developing I feel like with Sinbad
if you consider moggy the anime and the
Sinbad spin-off you get a lot more like
about him and like you know more about
him development and stuff so overall
he's a more complete character that's
not to say that Todoroki isn't going to
become more complete later
but as of things stand right now I'm
gonna go with Sinbad so for just one
moment before you you play too maybe
Todoroki will be cooler later which he
might in all honesty since the since
he's appearance in the stain fight
he was really dropping nobodies just not
getting much of screen time really yeah
because there's nothing they don't have
what to develop at this point it's like
his character arc is kind of done well
he know he was cute with more stuff to
do he was huge when there are exams yes
the the provisional license stuff he had
a moment there yeah without he didn't do
anything badass she saved his ass okay
you you know what you got to be man
enough to let a girl save your ass bro
absolutely but it doesn't make me a
badass
doesn't it though I don't know I
wouldn't Sinbad I don't know what I'm
[ __ ] arguing so Sinbad is two votes
so far yeah oh man it's all in Noble and
Briggs his court
I mean techie you don't even need am
awesome but I don't want to be the guy
just on hearsay like voting for a
character died know nothing about so I
gotta go Todoroki I'll be the one guy
fair I gotta stick with what I actually
I'm not actually know who Todoroki is I
do appreciate your help pushing Sinbad
to the ranks though but early the chat
called Sinbad ass the Kings I feel like
this fairly recently coming along with
that I also thought of an extremely
cringy nickname for Todoroki and that's
toka smokey channel try it and that in
noble votes
Claro he and it's all up to me I don't
want that to happen please vote first
Briggs
well at the voting left if I have to Oh
Oh God so you're forcing my vote now on
this matter
well toner okey here he's gotta battle
the two sides inside and you know like
whether he wants to like do his own path
or against his father constantly he's
kind of like at the top of the hero
thing now because everybody wants him
but he kind of wants to branch off and
do his own thing cuz his [ __ ]
father's messing up his entire life
constantly and you know he's got permis
cars he's got daddy issues he's got
women all around him just like Sinbad
but he just pushes them away because he
doesn't need them right now and like
same bed doesn't have a [ __ ] nation
Sinbad is like I can't justify tiller ok
just think about all the people on this
I can't I can't justify my Todoroki ever
seen bad I I have to choose think about
all the people who sit and who work
under Sinbad like how cool they are and
they are subordinate to Sinbad I know
nothing about them but they sound pretty
cool great to have you here man I can't
justify picking so look don't you like
to vote I don't even need to vote and I
don't want to I'm sorry I feel like we
screwed up you're just idiots here guys
I was gonna troll you guys so badly if
novo voted Todoroki then it would have
been it would have been too - and I
would have like hyped it up kind of
talked about the minute and it ends just
left no you would not have done that you
have hyped it up and said hey votes a
Kiki yeah I could've done that you know
we could shop open beers with these
planning on leaving I would just leave
it like it's done no one wins why are
you so triggered man because they both
[ __ ] no they're both awesome characters
okay you shouldn't leave him are in the
bracket tell you why window
that mine anyhow so the winner is Sinbad
guys yeah yeah that is definitely badass
like I would have preferred other
characters to win but he is definite
about us I'm happy with the results if
told her okay what about you I would
acquit Raptors like never show up again
you're banned sir
sweet Just Desserts though for one piece
winning last one I think what why did
she pick Todoroki over baka go for this
bracket I'm arias Oh nuts recommended it
when he said Todoroki I put him in I was
like I feel like I put so many other
characters in here there's a lot of
characters in it no one punch man love
no Saitama well that is not shown in
that is seinen but okay but I would have
honestly voted one punch man over
everyone on this list yeah I never
considered exempt except for may begin
Toki but I never considered it straight
up saying maybe I'm just used to
watching sane and health singers like
really [ __ ] bloody and stuff punch
man is ensuring jump but right I'm
pretty sure so then again so is death
note yeah
but based off of like the way like next
I kind of agreed I figured we don't
classify it as shown in but it isn't
shows right yeah that's fine I just
personally never classified it like that
but that's fine
well like he is like a 25 year old knee
to rather than like a high school
student in Seoul yeah well Sinbad is a
king and Eskimo is old as Alibaba a lot
and are the main guys in moggy
yeah but Simba is the badass yeah but
he's not the main guy anyways yeah no
he's a total [ __ ] like know he likes
boobs it's funny how you mentioned that
cuz like oh I know Alibaba who's the guy
with the sword
Alibaba okay yeah what are the last
chapters I read of man gene it was way
in the
early part was when Alibaba like broke
out the sword and was like badass and is
like oh he's a [ __ ] oh okay well I like
how a lot and he's like a little chibi
guy but he loves beer yeah I'll add it
and he's like eight or something yeah I
know who doesn't love boobs no no nobody
does you're eight years old man you
gotta love boobs
love is light yeah guys if you're happy
with these results don't yeah if you
hate it that's another thing dude I'm
just like in the video oh man all my all
my pretty bad yeah oh my super badass
was bad
alright so let's say it was all mine
just just for fun here let's say it was
all my all my vs. sinbad yeah I would
still vote sinbad a hundred percent but
almost no one does what we should do one
of these one day with like mean
characters like Lord Twigg oh and [ __ ]
Lord we going table from Code Geass and
stuff I title it meme wars well Minnie
Etta is a pretty [ __ ] meme too yeah
no I I honestly wanted to put him on
this badass list but I don't know Briggs
was not not for that he's more into that
he's a very sticky mean kinda I would
have thought me Netta versus esken or
would have been a good face-off oh yeah
Austin would be a total mean character
yeah where's asked yeah what the [ __ ] is
going on with black Laura bridge NOx we
don't talk about that at the beginning
of black clover a bridge you could just
cut together in orderto in fairy tale
and you'll be good yeah black clover
bridge great but we have a lot of the
prominent voices on this stream I know
I'm excited to hear it I want to hear it
I wanted to see it I don't want it to
happen man you want to touch me you want
to taste it you want to be yeah I want
to smell a little bit yeah Anna Mac
you're the best character do you
remember who yeah he's the what's his
what's his line he's
haha he's the bad guy I watched
sub-sites haha whatever Vegeta 1 for 2
to 7 de said this is ass haha that's you
your Vegeta 1 for 2 to 7 this was as the
last week's one this one was hilarious
and a great time and thank you everyone
for showing up pleasure to meet you
teching and Noble pleasure to be in a
speedo you guys - it's been a blast
wait you're that's me he's from the
channel swag cog eh that's right
swag cocky is someone else I need to
contact about that charity thing yeah
yeah did you do ask these guys ready I
asked you I asked these guys already
yeah you weren't here you were having
technical problems trying to figure you
were having technical issues when that
yeah when I asked them yeah so we'll
we'll be in touch deal brand oh yeah
another cool meme character for the
model pretty badass - yeah yeah tacking
to send me a DM maybe I'll do a bracket
way better than this one for that little
video I want to actually I'm curious to
see how noble describes his channel so
noble tell us who you are and what you
do alright I anime variety show and I do
stupid cringy [ __ ] that's what I [ __ ]
do it sounds like taking yeah I was
gonna test that no both both stand up
dudes and I enjoyed their content yeah
same here and my brother time fan
ducking because of the one piece stuff
yeah I do like like for a long time on
the channel I always acted the way I
acted no one called it cringy wasn't for
the last year and a half the people are
like man checking euchre in G but we
love you I'm like okay but sure but yeah
mostly one-piece stuff one punch man and
my your academia I'm getting into and so
come on over your one stop trend shop
god that was crazy one stop it's great
links in the description also we got
Briggs all day hand me the buttered boy
of the streams you have so butthurt a
lot of it it was a lot of fun though it
was a lot of fun at a good time good to
be here every week Wow oh yeah I'm break
from all the anime put what like and of
course we have NOx Taku hello it is me
next act who the guy with the technical
difficulties that probably sounds like
crap because he knows cuz he's on his
phone yeah like you saw it you saw angry
a lot of the time but I think that's
just that's just you charity thing sweet
yeah awesome well I do really weird
stuff in my channel super deep analysis
super weird mean cringe stuff and then
he explained why the chip scene in Death
Note is actually way more philosophical
than anything Nietzsche ever wrote wow
this is true but that was like an old
video you haven't seen my recent stuff
you ever feel like Nietzsche is kind of
overrated sometimes just because he's
like the go-to I do we could talk about
more about this in our philosophers
brackets all right separation out Thomas
Aquinas spoiler alert Rousseau versus
Plato is Shah would not win solvers has
played on you okay first off I hate
Aristotle he loses it's Plato's where
it's at
Plato iris told I like him but Plato and
restore where it's at Aquinas is also
good though I'd like I don't know man I
was thinking Russo's good but I don't
know how we do against mother's basement
picturing mother's basement have a
philosophy to with like Plato or
Socrates yeah he'd destroy them it's
it's time to wrap this up ladies and
gentlemen
um thank you everybody in the chat so
much for coming through and hanging out
I hope you're all triggered or super
happy or whatever thanks to
lovely guests on the panel pleasure to
have you and without any cringe at all
[ __ ] you Knox until next time
crece snatcher ever boys bang bang